قال وزير الخارجيه البرتغاليه جاو غوميز
جرافينيو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس في موقع
منافسه على القاره الافريقيه مع روسيا
واشار في تصريحات خاصه للجزيره على هامش
مشاركته كمراقب في اجتماعات وزراء
الخارجيه الافارقه بادس ابا الى ان علاقه
الاتحاد الاوروبي بافريقيا لم تتاثر
بالعدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا
تعد افريقيا جزءا بارزا جدا في سياستنا
الخارجيه ومع الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
ركزت اوروبا على هذا التهديد لامنها لكننا
بحاجه الى الدخول في حوار دائما مع
افريقيا لان العلاقه معها مهمه للغايه نحن
لسنا هنا للتنافس مع روسيا نعتقد ان غزوه
روسيا لاوكرانيا جعلها منبوذه في المجتمع
الدولي ومن الواضح اننا نحث روسيا على وقف
هذا الغزو على الفور لكن علاقتنا مع
القاره الافريقيه لن تتاثر بذلك